[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
laniel faut vraiment que tu arrêtes de
coucher avec tous les mecs c'est pas
possible ça
ne serait pas vrai madame c'est mon
petit fils j'ai des
bêtises les amis bienvenue dans un
nouveau numéro 2 je suis pas au courant
de ma propre vie
thiam et diane lane france abonnements
ils sont ensemble yes je sens un sujet
las vegas je comprends pas il ya que moi
que ça arrive que je suis pas au courant
de ma vie on m'apprend des trucs sur ma
vie proche de miss france pourquoi moi
j'apprends ma vie de région nous tout le
temps que je produis miss france moi je
crois qu'il est proche du taux jeu
sommes aussi prêts j'étais proche de toi
ce qu'est vadalle ce nom mais tout le
temps il fait des relations lui tout le
temps tu as tu fait je suis une relation
que des miss france miss univers au fait
sa vie lui de son côté il a eu plus de
mal à refaire sa vie ce molosse
[Musique]
e
beaucoup de
personnes à jal car le nouveau batman
dure pratiquement trois heures bon je
leur dis heureusement que ce n'est pas
moi qui joue ce batman car sinon le film
il pu dû y aurait pratiquement six
heures
bonjour jean claude alors moi j'ai
cherché dans ma garde-robe à tf1 et j'ai
eu aucun mal à trouver des vêtements qui
met évoqué des souvenirs j'ai donc
choisi ces deux blousons en cuir que tu
va reconnaître celui là c'était en
pleine coupe du monde en 2018 pour le
premier match des bleus celui là je les
portais le soir de la finale et on sait
comment ça s'est terminé avec une
deuxième étoile sur le maillot de
l'équipe de france donc on peut le dire
ces deux blousons ce sont les petits pur
bonheur et j'allais même dire tu es mon
porte bonheur je sais pas si tu te
souviens mais c'est avec une d'été tenu
que j'ai présenté mon premier jt gym a
aussi offert mon premier buzz avec cette
magnifique robe en cuir rouge et puis tu
m'as offert aussi à ma première robe
longue pour mon premier gala alors je
voulais te remercier de m'avoir tendu la
main avec autant d'amitié il ya quelques
années quand j'ai frappé à sa porte je
t'embrasse très fort